[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre émission face à la
première comme chaque fin de semaine
diffusé en direct le vendredi à 14
heures si vous notre superbe la première
point fr notre site internet et puis sur
notre radio
une émission à retrouver le dimanche à
12 heures notre invité cette semaine
jean philippe miller bonjour massoni
londres je vous rejoins tous ceux qui
nous regardent et ceux qui nous écoutent
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes député conseiller à
l'assemblée de martinique membre de la
direction du mime le mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais une
émission que j'ai le plaisir aujourd'hui
de présenter avec mon confrère bertrand
carouge bertrand banques sont bertrand
bonjour bonjour à vous tous bonjour jean
marc bonjour jean philippe mongeau
bertrand et pour commencer l'émission
comme sacrifie à la tradition de
quelques questions d'actualité
brièvement c'est bien trois quarts où là
il va vous proposer ce premier est la
première question a trait à l'actualité
chez nous avec ce qui se passe du côté
du prêcheur du morne-rouge seul art
un nom qui revient un peu à la mode avec
ce qui s'est passé en fait bon il s'agit
d'une importante coulée de boue ou un
glissement de terrain
desrochers et de la terre et de l'eau
qui donc c'est cool et met en danger les
populations de ces communes
alors
le député que vous êtes mais aussi le
citoyen martiniquais comment il a réagi
à ça comment vous observer ce phénomène
naturel un peu inquiétant quand même oui
c'est un peu inquiétant
j'étais a été appelé en tant que citoyen
et martinique est simplement j'ai tenu à
me rendre sur place pour porter vrai
témoignage de solidarité à la population
prix chutent in et aux mères du prêcheur
donc j'ai un autre chat avec lui pour
que je me soucie un peu de de son état
d'esprit et il m'a rassuré ça c'est ça
c'est très bien très bien passé et je
crois que c'est toute la population de
la martinique qui est qu'ils allaient
coûte
c'est vrai que les informations les plus
contradictoires
c'est ok comme d'habitude comme à
l'accoutumée je crois que thouars et
mêmes quelquefois peut-être pas
forcément exact oui mais c'est savez
nous sommes fous dans le le monde
d'échecs et il est devenu très difficile
désormais de faire le tri entre le vrai
le faux et vous avez des professionnels
de la diffusion du faux etc c'est l'un
des enjeux de la communication dans les
décennies à venir tous les jours voire
même victime
nous les journalistes en général pas de
notre média martin première mois
seulement politiquement je pense être
victime de ça et y compris à ces
personnes ou alors si vous le souhaitez
une autre question ces questions de
d'aléas naturels nous sommes soumis à
quasiment presque tous les aléas
naturels son ami séismes éruptions
volcaniques ou les deux bouts
inondations ouragans extrême la
population martin quasi parfaitement
informée de ce que il faut se comporter
différemment les élus politiques les
responsables administratifs le savent
également mais on a l'impression que tu
n'as pas grand chose qui bouge pour
réaménager le territoire pour se loger
différemment pour construire des
infrastructures différemment comme si
entre la prise de conscience et les
acteurs réels il ya un fossé que nous
combes lanta en boutade j'aurais dit
informé mais peut-être pas suffisamment
formés
je me demande si elle est suffisamment
informés déjà mais vous savez c'est tout
toute la difficulté qu'il ya entre les
intentions qui sont affichées les moyens
qui sont octroyés véritablement nous
avons eu ces derniers mois deux
phénomènes majeurs cyclonique en
l'occurrence dans la caraïbe
il ya une émotion légitime nous avons
été épargnés nous martiniquais ne peut
pas ce que l'oeil du cyclone est passé
très près de nous contrairement à nos
voisins de la dominique par exemple mais
pas question pour autant qu'elle
complètement il protège et immuniser en
quelque sorte on est loin d'être d'être
protégé c'est à dire que nous les zones
micro insulaire de la caraïbe nous
sommes les premières victimes d'un
phénomène de dérèglement climatique qui
est aux castrais dans les pays
continentaux les pays les plus
développés dans les pays riches
l'irresponsabilité des politiques qui
ont été menées jusqu'ici notamment au
regard de la nécessité de protéger
l'environnement
cette irresponsabilité là c'est nous qui
la payons cash
il faudra s'habituer à des cyclones de
300 350 km/heure désormais c'est ce
qu'on nous dit alors il faudra
s'habituer et mettre parce que vous
commencez votre propos par
l'inadéquation entre les propos et les
moyens de mise en oeuvre
mais il faut des moyens au delà d'elle
de l'émotion qui est légitime
quelles politiques sont mises en oeuvre
véritablement pour faire face à ces
nouveaux dangers
je crois et c'est l'une des propositions
que je fais que j'ai déjà fait mais que
je vais continuer de porter entre que
parlementaire pas seulement avec les
parlementaires de martinique mais aussi
entre les parlementaires de toutes ces
régions
dites aux hauts de france outre mer
nous allons porter l'idée et la
nécessité que l'état français prenne ses
responsabilités et mettre mettre en
place un véritable plan marshall pour la
sécurisation des logements nous ne
pouvons pas bénéficié des mêmes normes
en matière de construction que en france
par exemple donc qui dit normes plus
exigeantes dit aussi des coûts plus
élevés et il faut qu'il y ait un
véritable plan avec des financements
associés des financements appropriés
pour mettre aux normes le parc de
logements qu'il s'agisse de logements
privés ou de logement public dans nos
territoires et ça c'est une demain car
légitime dans un cadre vous faites
référence à l'état pour terminer sur ce
chapitre parce qu'on a une autre
question d'actualité à vous poser j'en
suis dit miller mais ce serait se
seraient sous dans le cadre d'un
partenariat un vrai partenariat entre
collectivités locales enfin
collectivités de pays on va dire que
l'activité pays est l'état où est-ce que
c'est tellement vaste et a tellement de
moyens à mettre en oeuvre que c'est
l'état tout seul qui doit quelque part
impulse est enclenchée être le
personnellement je ne suis pas de ceux
qui demandent à l'état de tout prendre
en charge et je considère que même pour
traduire une volonté politique des
acteurs locaux des acteurs des élus du
territoire
il est plus pertinent est de bonne
politique c'est un beau symbole que de
pouvoir s'impliquer dans les politiques
qui sont qui sont mises en oeuvre chez
nous y compris au niveau des
financements dans la mesure de mes
moyens disponibles bien évidemment mais
il ne sut une telle politique ne soit
être mise en oeuvre sans la
participation des des collectivités
territoriales de nos territoires
une autre question d'actualité à vendre
venir à la situation politique le climat
politique dans le pays et puis votre
actualité votre activité de député
j'avais des brûlures sacha que rien de
ce qui nous qui est humain ne nous est
étranger vous avez sûrement entendu
parler des déclarations controversées de
la dernière déclaration controversée du
président trompe enfin déclarations
controversées twem c'est un peu et
pléonasme bien évidemment sur haïti les
pays africains ne comprend pourquoi il
n'ya pas aux états unis d'immigrés
venant par exemple de norvège il ya
majoritairement des gens qui viennent
d'afrique noire ont évidemment c'est
parti comme ça mais si vous dépensez ou
d'haïti ou des pays de ces gens pauvres
et évidemment il a un peu édulcoré son
propos il ya un de ses conseillers a dit
que c'est comme ça que parler pense la
base électorale du président américain
donc ça laisse perplexe quand
personnages à cette importance aux noces
de telles stars au tout tout de même
selon le washington post parce que c'est
le washington post qui a rapporté
d'après des témoins qui ont parlé mais
c'est ce que dit ce grand journal
américain quand même washington post
pourquoi voici comment donald trump se
serait exprimé pourquoi est ce que
toutes ces personnes issues de pays de
merde viennent ici fin de citation
en parlant d'haïti et de pays africains
de nations africaines
ces propos sont non seulement choquant
mais sans révolte rend le plus grave
le plus triste c'est que ils viennent du
plus grand responsable politique d'un
des plus d'un des pays les plus
puissants de la planète
d'où les limites du mode de scrutin
riquiqui qui est observée lors des
élections présidentielles aux états unis
mais ce qui est le plus inquiétant c'est
que visiblement il ya une masse de
personnes dans ce pays là qui passent
comme leur président ce que le président
et ses panneaux mais il a été élu quel
que soit le mode de scrutin elle a été
soutenue alors que l'on savait bien
qu'il était qui avait le profil sujette
à débordement on peut dire moi je crois
profondément que ce monsieur est un
raciste comme il y en a beaucoup
pas sûr dans ce monde et sa présence aux
plus hautes responsabilités constituer
un danger pour la planète entière
il a obtenu 46% des suffrages populaires
48% contre son adversaire démocrate
hillary clinton donc arrivé en tête des
suffrages populaires et 6% pour les deux
autres candidats une écologiste
candidats indépendants mais ses 46% cela
c'est déjà ça doit nous interpeller
peut-être que certains regrettent c'est
leur choix mais en tout cas que dans ce
pays là on est ce type de profil là à la
tête
je crois que c'est s'inquiétant et ça
doit susciter chez nous un sentiment de
révolte de rébellion mais aussi mettre
en avant des stratégies intelligentes
pour pouvoir contrer le risque potentiel
de ce type d'individu nous sommes dans
face à la première l'émission politique
hebdomadaire de martinique la première
sur internet et en radio avec
jean-philippe milan député de martinique
manque de l'assemblée de martinique
membre de la direction nationale du
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
justement comment va le mime après
quelques semaines où il ya eu disons des
turbulences en externe et en interne la
crise du mime va-t-elle déboucher sur
une scission entre marie jeanne east ni
l'hommiste et puis d'offres puisqu'il ya
beaucoup de militants militantes qui ne
veulent pas choisir entre ce bord et
cinq ans c'est la présentation que vous
faites moi c'est passé le reste c'est
une question dont on a déjà parlé de
marie jeanne est une île où rist
personnellement je ne m'inscris pas dans
ce type de logique là à partir du moment
où on adjoint suffixe east après un nom
propre je ne m'inscris pas dans ça
je crois que au sein d'un parti
politique quel qu'il soit dans son
histoire
il ya toujours des zones de turbulences
il faut qu'il y ait débat réellement
essais delà du débat de la divergence
quenelle enrichissement c'est dans cette
logique que je me situe
et je ne peux pas aujourd'hui parler de
risque de scission de rupture il ya un
débat qui est menée il ya des visions
qui peuvent être différentes
et c'est tout à fait normal parce que
j'ai comme comment les militants du mime
comment les martiniquaises et les
martiniquais doivent-ils interpréter ce
propos du président du mim alfred marie
jeanne
en parlant de vous interpeller par un
auditeur sur rld m la radio du mime
quand il répond messieurs c'est pas
dépité - comment doivent interpréter ce
propos les militants du mime et de
manière plus globale les martiniquais ce
propos là c'est pas un propos erronés
je reçus par le député d'alfred marie je
suis le député du sud
élu par le peuple du sud et le député de
la martinique
c'est aussi simple jeu je crois que sur
ce front là ce n'est pas discutable
heureusement que je ne suis jeune et je
n'appartiens pas à quelqu'un je fus je
considère que c'est très sain de ne pas
être le député d'une personne alors vous
dites qu'il y ait un débat au sein du
mime et comment dans une des formations
politiques entre des options différentes
des visions différentes mais qu'est ce
qui fait débat aujourd'hui même qu
est-ce qui ont pas vous oppose mais
qu'est ce qui provoque des des
dissensions des désaccords qu'ils soient
internes ont exprimé sur la place
publique
d'après vous est ce qu'il ya vraiment
des visions stratégiques des conceptions
du monde complètement différent de voir
différentes à l'intérieur de votre
formation et conception ne sont pas
complètement différentes sinon on
n'aurait rien à faire dans le même parti
les conceptions et les stratégies
peuvent diverger
par exemple les pratiques c'est que
auxquels on a des auquel on adhère pas
je veux dire le choix de voter à
l'élection présidentielle c'est un choix
qui a été celui du mime pendant plus de
40 ans moi je ne peux pas changer
d'option sans un débat réel dans
l'internât par exemple passé c'est tout
à fait normal en tout cas moi c'est le
point de vue que je défends je vais le
défendre et où il y attendre une
décision d'un personnel du président du
nord a dit m ça a été une décision qui
engage et le président d'accord mais
vous savez l'amalgamé est vite fait
entre les positions qui sont prises par
le président les positions qui sont
prises qui sont prises par le parti
puis bon jeu on va passer sur ça je
crois je considère qu'il faut aller de
l'avant mais a eu des choix de deux
soutiens de candidats aux différentes
élections que je n'ai pas approuvé
personnellement j'ai essuyé cette
désapprobation et aux élections
législatives sénatoriales ça a commencé
depuis les municipales de 2014
donc voilà mais c'est de cette richesse
là que l'on doit pouvoir décider quelque
chose de positif est tout de même les
divergences ont tendance à s'accumuler
quand même depuis quelque temps ce qui
n'était pas le cas il ya encore quatre
cinq ans alors ce n'était pas aussi
public voilà ça l'intelligence des
choses sont publiés ce n'est pas de mon
fait ce n'est pas de votre fait alors
votre explication messieurs s'est pas
dit pit est moins bon elle est valable
bien sûr mais peut-être un peu oui mais
elle ne peut peut-être pas se résumer
qu'à ça parce que alfred marie-jeanne
répondait à cet auditeur qui vous avait
désigné comme il appelait un soutien à
vous soutenir
il disait faut que nous soutient dépité
noah sera nière ce que les choux une
affaire bien précis seul à le faire
alberman bon voilà et alfred
marie-jeanne lui répond spontanément
attention non mais c'est pas dépité -
alors que le dieter englobait fze voilà
tenait un propos de solidarité voyez
voilà donc
interrogé sur quoi bien sûr est-ce que
ça amène une réponse complémentaire de
votre part sur ce sur sept ce à rosny
mans le terme serait peut-être un peu
trop fort mais cette distance en tout
cas prise par alfred marie-jeanne
vis-à-vis de vous c'est une déclaration
qui a été faite par monsieur alfred
marie-jeanne c'est lui qu'il faudrait
interroger moi je fais pas un
psychanalyste je suis pas spécialiste de
sa communication donc c'est lui qu'il
faudrait interroger là dessus en tout
cas moi je dis je répète que je ne suis
pas son député comme je suis le député
de dubuc du moi je suis le député de
tout le monde de toute la population en
cnct
nous avons constaté également que les
dissensions ont dû public en est au
coeur du mime affecter l'unité la
cohérence de la majorité de la
collectivité territoriale de manon ça
c'est une extrapolation que vous faites
ce sont pas forcément les difficultés ou
le les débats qui ont lieu à l'intérieur
du même et qui doivent j'insiste là
dessus
restez à l'intérieur du mime
ce ne sont pas ces débats là où ces
divergences qui alimente forcément
d'autres divergences dans la majorité
alors comment expliquer la sortie dans
le froid de marie-jeanne contre claude
lise le président de l'assemblée selon
laquelle celui ci serait l'auteur où
l'acteur d'un complot contre lui et donc
depuis les relations entre les deux
hommes sont particulièrement rafraîchie
à la même émission est même que j'ai
même question même réponse c'est pas moi
qu'il faut demander d'expliquer les
propos de vue du président divine
j'espère vous allez le recevoir j'ai là
dessus aussi s'il souhaite en parler
c'est plutôt dire son assentiment que
peut-être que tu fiction peut-être qu'il
ne souhaite pas en parler parce que ici
70 ans du compte que ses propos avaient
été un peu outrance il sait que c'est
impossible c'est possible en tout cas
s'il souhaite pas en parler je pense que
beaucoup de martinique et de narguer
attend les dix années qui est résolument
athée mais quelle somme des explications
mais je crois que les martinez 15
éléments scéniques et attendent
davantage des réponses des comptes
rendus de l'activité des politiques
quelques postes qu'ils occupent
je crois que les martiniquais et les
martiniquais attend des projets des
perspectives des actions concrètes les
visions les conceptions de l'avenir
vous parliez vous parliez de débats qui
lui sait plus comment ce que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure qu'il faudra faut
être plus attentif
non non non non dans la vie du parti du
mime vous appeliez a peut-être à
clarifier les choses allaient si c'est
pas exactement le propos c'est pas lui
mots vous avez utilisé mais mais c'était
avant dans l'esprit mais ma question est
toute simple c'est quel est le prochain
rendez vous démocratique interne pour le
mime prochain dé voir ce sera un congrès
je sais pas comment vous appelez ça
non un séminaire qui est en suspens
depuis un moment on on attend que la
décision soit prise de manière
collégiale de faire ce séminaire là vous
impatientez en plus on le sent non non
non je me passionne pas du tout
contrairement à ce que vous pouvez vous
imaginer je suis très serein et plus que
jamais déterminés qui terminait à quoi
déterminé à faire valoir les idées les
principes pour lesquels je me bats je ne
suis pas seul je crois que aujourd'hui
nous devons est tous partis politiques
confondus adopter une autre posture une
autre dimanche être davantage à l'écouté
des préoccupations est de réponse après
avoir permis un enrichissement par tout
un chacun les forces vives de notre
société n'est plus question de prendre
des décisions stratégiques importantes
dans un bureau climatisé tout seul
aujourd'hui il faut être au coeur du
peuple il faut être dans le peuple pour
pouvoir faire ou à monter ses
inspirations et à terme émettre des
propositions et est porteur et incarner
un projet qui a du sens parce qu'il
vient du peuple
alors justement le peuple quand vous
entendez puisque vous êtes au coeur du
peuple
vous savez bien qu'il est circonspecte
perplexe frustré un patient du faible du
peu de résultats de la faible
performance de la ctm qui au bout de
deux ans a du mal à se stabiliser en
interne et en externe on a l'impression
que cette machine ce mammouth a beaucoup
de difficultés de fonctionnement et qui
ne correspond pas à ce que la population
attendait finalement bon il ya deux
choses il ya les difficultés de
fonctionnement qui sont liés à des
problèmes budgétaires des problèmes que
nous avons trouvé et je le reconnais que
nous avons mal mesuré à notre arrivée
avait été fait l'audit recommande
d'ailleurs pour le rendre public cet
audit a été rendu public
douze mois récemment il ya des
difficultés ya eu de vraies difficultés
elles ont été sous-évalués j'insiste là
dessus
et puis lorsque vous parlez d'incapacité
ou de résultats insuffisants
certes peut-être certainement faut
pouvoir faire amende honorable mais on
ne peut pas les 100 tonnes quand il y en
a se fait que vous avez assisté à au
bilan de deux ans d'activité on a vu les
conseillers exécutifs de la collectivité
présenté le bilan de leur action
donc peut pas dire au terme d'une telle
présentation que rien ne se fait il faut
pas non plus exagérer dans l'autre sens
donc ceci dit je n'avais pas trop dit
dieu ça ici on n'a pas dit que rien ne
va on a dit que beaucoup de personnes
sont impatients tous frustrés de ce que
la 7e finalement a du mal
troisième volet des difficultés ce sont
des difficultés qui sont liées par la
loi je considère que la loi qui a régi 7
l'installation la mise en oeuvre de
cette collectivité territoriale de
martinique est largement perfectible et
c'est aussi ça fait ça fait partie des
démissions que nous en tant que
parlementaire nous devons nous assigner
permettent de parfaire ce cadre
législatif qui pose problème à mon
niveau
vous allez demander une modification de
la loi une amie une amélioration de la
loi instaurant la collectivité
territoriale de martinique la loi de
juillet 2011 alors que
c'est difficile de parler d'institutions
de changements institutionnels puisque
il est même interdit au sein de la
majorité d'évoquer la question du statut
qui est différente c'est vrai mais
est-ce que je vais remettre cacher la
vérité vos informations en commun
commandes de me dire à moi qu'il est
interné dans la majorité de parler du
statut de ces facteurs qui impactent de
gestion qui décide et les composantes de
la majorité ont terminé le montre autres
dans les erreurs du n'est pas évoquée
durant un an
non non ce que ce pacte dit précisément
c'est que la question du statut n'est
pas prioritaire durant l'exercice de son
mandat
mais ça ne savait pas dire qu'il
interdit de parler de statut et encore
moins d'évolution des institutions et
d'aménagement institutionnels vous
imaginez la contradiction si l'état
français lui-même comme ce gouvernement
s'apprête à le faire en temps au revoir
la constitution réunir le congrès pour
proposer une autre lecture notre
appréciation de l'article 72 de la
constitution pour croiser le l'antique
73 pourquoi l'article 74 serait laissé
de côté ce serait irresponsable de notre
titre 72 juste sans rentrer dans le
droit constitutionnel permet à la loi de
créer une collectivité comme on dirige
de libre exercice original construit ges
si généreuse comme la nouvelle calédonie
comme la corse comme encore la barbie
donc souvent en soit resté à côté de ce
débat là ceci dit mais je maintiens
convaincre partenaires de la majorité
notamment l'ailé droite de la majorité
qui ne veut pas tellement évoqué des
questions statutaires problème d'après
yan monplaisir chez un ami mais chacun a
son identité et 6 dont chacun doit être
respectée aussi dans son identité mais
c'est pas parce qu'il ya eu ce pacte de
de gestion de la collectivité que je
deviens un homme de droite ou mon
plaisir est alors dites moi en tant que
député puisque vous passez d'une
instance a lot de la sonde et de
martinique à l'assemblée nationale
française pour parler comme la mine
à quoi sert d'être à quoi sert-il d'être
député indépendantiste
pourquoi député indépendantiste et la
constitution et qu'elle est parfois ça
sert un député autonomiste rue mais nous
avons posé la question en dépit des
listes qui nous expliquaient ce nom
parce qu'il ya un amalgame qui peut être
faire rapidement entre le fait de
députés et le fait d'aller demander
l'indépendance à la france entre que
d'habitude non c'est pas le rôle d'un
député d'aller me ni demander encore
moins exiger même pas négocier une
indépendance donc c'est pas comme ça que
les choses se passent il faut qu'il faut
être clair là dessus après je dis que
lorsqu'un député nationaliste
lorsqu'un député est animé de la
nécessité de défendre son peuple sans
pays son économie sa culture son sport
son environnement il est forcément à mon
sens à mon humble avis plus vigilants
qu'un député qui s'inscrirait dans une
démarche globale où l'identité la
personnalité la nécessité de défendre
véritablement les intérêts du pays
serait noyée jeudi ont aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on regarde la configuration de
l'assemblée nationale française vaut
mieux avoir un député indépendantiste
qui siègent au sein du groupe gdr qu'un
député e manche qu'ils soient noyés dans
la masse
en revanche je me remettais beaucoup
plus critique d'être beaucoup plus libre
de faire des propositions objectif
oui je fais comme vous on va passer
l'assemblée nationale à l'assemblée de
la ctm et inversement donc je reviens
sur cette période
maintenant terminée on peut le dire de
rodage de la cité même si encore des
choses à mettre en place
est-ce que vous adhérez ou est-ce que
vous compatit c'est en quelque sorte aux
blues qu'a eu claude lise
concernant les moyens qui lui était
donnée pour assumer sa fonction de
président de l'assemblée de la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
de ce point de vue est ce que aussi dans
le cadre de la loi est ce que parce que
c'est ce qu'il préconisait ce qu'il
suggère il voudrait que ce soit modifié
et puis il se plaignait un peu dès que
l'assemblée est lui en tant que
président de l'assemblée soit un peu
marginalisé pour un mois moi je
considère que cette collectivité
territoriale de martinique
elle doit reposer sur deux piliers c'est
un apprentissage qui est difficile parce
que on change vraiment de culture par
rapport à ce qu'on a on a connu on avait
connu précédemment créé que et qu'il
s'agisse du conseil général du conseil
régional une assemblée délibérante
on dirait un peu pour extrapoler une
assemblée nationale comme l'assemblée
nationale en france qui l'assemblée de
martinique un exécutif qui serait comme
un gouvernement et les relations entre
une assemblée délibérante qui est
constituée d'élus et un exécutif sont
souvent des relations de confrontation
même lorsque l'on fait partie d'une même
majorité parce qu'on ne défend pas le
même point de vue et et et l'assemblée
doit jouer son rôle de contrôle de
l'exécutif
et pour jouer ce rôle là l'assemblée
doit pouvoir disposer de moyens pour
fonctionner ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et ça fait partie des
évolutions souhaitables de du cadre
législatif donc sur ce point là je suis
en parfaite cohérence en parfait accord
avec le président claude lise ça fait
pas de moi pour autant un comploteur
tout à l'heure vous disiez vous avez
vous qui le faites que vous allez
travailler en parfaite unique ans
harmonie avec les autres parlementaires
de martinique et des députés
hors de france des territoires de france
manuel mondésir on vient de remplacer
bruno nestor azérot qui est votre ami
votre frère comme il est nécessaire de
le proclamer depuis plusieurs années
vous n'avez pas les mêmes relations
évidemment avec elle puisque je suppose
que vous n'avez pas les plus récentes
dans comment dirais-je dans le jeu
politique phare et puis vous en
connaissez vous une autoradio sous
d'autres auspices
comment se passent les relations en
général au sein et entre les quatre
députés de martinique qui est avec la
nouvelle en particulier partis qui
siègent ou d'un même groupe que vous et
qui siège maintenant comme gdr siège aux
objets délaissés comme génération de
traitements chose je dois vous dire
souvent j'entends des railleries
s'agissant des relations que
j'entretiens avec bouleaux nestor azérot
on parle de frère damien un peu un peu
avec un peu d'ironie mais ce sont des
choses qu'il faut respecter dans la vie
et le fait d'être amis le fait d'être
frères ça veut pas dire que là est une
photocopie de l'autre je crois au
contraire
voilà un exemple patent où la différence
peut faire une force et dans la relation
que nous avons développées pendant ces
cinq années de notre première mandature
je veux dire à certains moments au delà
des divergences réelles idéologique que
l'on peut avoir
heureusement qu'on était deux pour
discuter pour comprendre certaines
choses pour apprendre ensemble vous
confronter des points de vue pressé de
sortir des positions des interventions
des votes plus objectif heureusement
cette différence là car entre nous parce
que je suis pas le jumeau d'un zéro ça a
permis de nous enrichir mutuellement et
ça ce qui fait que finalement
on sent et je peux le dire quand même
pas mal sorti pour une première
mandature
mais la nouvelle députée la nouvelle
carrière un profil ma carrière je dirais
un peu particulier elle est issue des
rangs du ppm quand même même si elle n'y
est plus
elle est conseillère municipale me
semble-t-il l'adjointe au maire de saint
joseph qui pas vraiment votre ami
politique
bon c'est pas voilà alors on fait fi de
tout ça on va au delà tout ça est entre
parlementaires entre députés ont fait
primer l'intérêt général ou bien
heureusement
est-ce que vous l'aurez heureusement on
attendait bien avec elle vous avez déjà
je m'entendais très bien avec elle même
lorsqu'elle était dans la majorité de du
conseil régional moi je siégeais dans
l'opposition je crois que on peut pas
avoir un procès pour kankan permanent et
avoir aussi un procès pour volonté ou
tentatives de réconciliation il faut
faire la part des choses très
franchement je le dis à ceux qui nous
écoutent
c'est pas parce qu'on défend des points
de vue différents que nous devons être
ennemis nous sommes des adversaires
politiques à certains moments nous ne
sommes pas les ennemis parce que si on
commence à se considérer comme ennemi
dans notre pays quelles perspectives on
va offrir à la relève aux jeunes je vous
prends un exemple
même les israéliens et les palestiniens
arrive à conclure des cessez le feu
c'est à dire vous compter les blessés
pour soigner les blessés pour compte
éléments il arrive à imposer une trêve
on sait la haine qu les oppose et chez
nous on a l'impression que ya une guerre
larvée lens il note mais sans repos
113-100 maman et c'est ça qui nous
discrédite tous autant que nous sommes
tous autant que nous sommes des plus
grand au plus petit et c'est ça ce n'est
pas ce que nous devons porter à la
martinique sé pa diot qui suffit de se
mettre autour d'une autour d'une table
pour régler tous les problèmes qui se
posent dans notre pays je suis pas dans
cette vision mais vous parlez de manuela
mon désir nous avons par exemple en tant
qu'élus nous avons eu l'occasion de
partir faire des formations suivent
bénéficier de formations auront de
martinique est forcément des liens se
créent des liens se tissent et c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai toujours respecté qui
m'a toujours respecté
finalement vous allez et je considère
que la martinique aura une très bonne
députée elle peut venir et peu provenant
des rangs du bbm en tout cas elle siège
au sein du groupe gdr et
le travail que
j'ai mené pendant ces cinq ans en
étroite collaboration avec vous donner
soit 0 va se poursuivre avec manuela mon
désir sans aucune difficulté
en essayant d'en d'élargir et d'intégrer
les deux autres parlementaires avec qui
je n'ai pas de problèmes relationnels
personnel j'ai une dernière une question
sur cet aspect documentaire et à josette
manin
et bien justement j'avais parlé vous
faites bien de citer josette manal je
remarque puisque j'allais vous demandez
à vous le féminisme que vous êtes
gentils du pilote va dépend de ce que
vous appelez féministe vous êtes pour
l'égalité entre hommes et femmes le
progrès pour le droit des femmes
mais bien sûr je suis le progrès pour
nos adhérents comme pour le doigt de
toutes les minorités viol ou de tous
ceux qui suivent d'ajuster après
l'exercice de l'année dernière la
martinique se retrouve avec trois
parlementaires femmes c'est bien alors
qu'il ya peu de temps on n'avait aucune
josette manin est arrivé manuela déclare
mon désir et catherine conconne au sénat
vous saluer cette évolution ce progrès
même peut-être au sein de la société je
salue cette présence féminine show
regrette que au sein de mon parti on a
pas fait confiance à des femmes qui ont
un intérêt cavallo potentiel de venir
enrichir cet arsenal d'élus femme est
porteur de nouvelles perspectives pour
la matinée nous sommes dans face à la
première l'émission politique
hebdomadaire de martinique la première
sur internet et sur la radio vous avez
soutenu jacques philippe milan qui est
notre invité aujourd'hui la proposition
de loi déposée il ya quelques jours par
an serge chimie pour modifier le régime
de l'indivision successorale
comme beaucoup d'autres parlementaires d
outre-mer puisque cette loi si elle est
votée va s'appliquer aux cinq départs
entre notre merde c'est un exemple
d'après vous de ne pas de fusion m
d'unités de traces de travail qu'il
faudrait avoir entre parlementaires
quelles que soient les divergences
idéologiques
oui ma réponse est oui clairement et un
nouvel état d'esprit qui est en train
d'émerger moi je
je salue ce c'est ambiance nouvelle
parce que je crois que tout un chacun
peut comprendre mais j'espère que c'est
durablement que on peut lorsqu'on en
martinique s'opposer mais lorsqu'on
prend l'avion pour les défendre les
intérêts de la vente unique
on n'a pas à les afficher des cancans
aux yeux et au su de tout là-haut
présentation française
il ya des dossiers comme celui de la
santé comme celui de la culture comme
celui de l'indivision et tant d'autres
comme celui du développement économique
des difficultés du btp d'une législation
à faire avancer faut protéger la santé
des martiniquais contre l'empoisonnement
de la martinique
l'un des dossiers qui ne souffre pas de
différence de partis politiques mais par
contre il est important de corriger les
choses
j'entends que cette loin et c'est pas du
camp que je fais mais je porte une
information cette loi n'a pas été déposé
par le collègue letchimy le collègue
letchimy et rapporteur de la loi il est
cosignataire de la loi et nous sommes
d'accord pour que sur un sujet il y en
ait un d'entre nous 4 qui prennent le
leadership et les autres sont derrière
mais les autres sont derrière savait pas
dire qu'ils disent amen vous savez bien
que je ne suis pas celui de marché dans
l'autre sens merci mais ça va marcher
dans l'autre sens avec bien sûr quelques
textes quelques jours de théorie jeudi à
reggio battre des flots et les chaises
sont votre texte dans la complémentarité
du texte qui est proposé de la
proposition de loi sur la division mais
ce sera une proposition de loi qui va
concerner les logements en procédure
d'abandon manifeste parce qu'elle l'a
aussi s'agit d'une véritable paix au
sein même de nos villes au sein même de
nos quartiers etc c'est un blocage
quelque part au développement de
l'activité eau à l'occupation d'un
logement
aussi à des travaux du btp cette
question des logements abandonnés sans
propriétaire connu c'est un véritable
problème dans notre pays donc lui comme
nous avons déjà commencé et on voit si
on pourra travailler à discuter et pour
résoudre ça oui nous nous en discutons
avec les professionnels aidés par les
professionnels et nous espérons dans
quelques mois arrivait à faire et là
vous trouviez se rapportant à la
question que je sois pas le rapporteur
mais l'auteur gendarmes l'opposition la
proposition mais mais mais je veux dire
que le le texte l'initiative est
excellente
à mon avis le fait de travailler
ensemble et même si sur ce texte là nous
avons consenti à accepter que serge
letchimy elle est l'idole le leadership
et qu' il soit le rapporteur est quelque
part celui qui a alimenté concrètement
le contenu de cette loi qui comporte
quatre articles mais c'est pas pour
autant que je vais valider des choses
qui ne me paraissent pas tout à fait
cohérente et je serai t cette semaine la
semaine qui vient porter de toute une
batterie d'amendements poussée de corse
et le texte vous essayez de le rendre
surtout applicables parce que je dois
dire qu'en l'état actuel de sa rédaction
il risque de ne pas passer premièrement
l'écueil du conseil constitutionnel et
deuxièmement ils ne risquent de ne pas
être suffisamment incitatif suffisamment
applicable et nature les notaires
peut-être nouveau choisir de ne pas
l'appliquer
et puis une dimension qui n'est pas
intégré dans ce texte là c'est la partie
financière parce ce qui pose problème
c'est de cette histoire de soultz on
doit payer lorsqu'il ya lorsqu'un
partage et si il n'y a aucun voulait
financiers dans le texte
ça risque d'être encore une fois
un texte une copie vide plein de
déclaration debout bonnes déclarations
de bonnes intentions mais qui ne portent
pas véritablement un des faits
concrètement au pays donc il faut se
méfier de des présentations qui sont
faites qui peuvent être très belle très
séduisante sur le papier mais j'ai
appris avec le temps à faire la
différence entre le virtuel et le réel
alors une dernière question concernant
votre activité parlementaire quelles
sont vos relations avec le député
indépendantiste de tahiti mot times
bronson ou encore les trois députés
autonomistes cance et qui veut ne se
cachent pas ils sont venus pour n'ont
pas négocié me rendre de populariser la
lutte de leurs peuples respectifs
élégance pour l'autonomie vacances la
france est un pays ami pour la cancel
aussi c'est autonomiste est-ce que vous
travaillez vous que vous avez à vous
demander si vous êtes dans une autre
dimension à ce moment
oui j'ai d'excellentes relations avec
les députés cos notamment sur jean félix
acquaviva qui est un amateur de football
comme moi même donc ça rapproche
forcément et dès son arrivée la tenir en
contact avec moi pas seulement avec moi
mais avec d'autres élus nous avons un
moment envisagé la création de groupes
nos goûts communs ça n'a pas pu se faire
mais ça n'empêche que nous travaillons
ensemble nous échangeons nous partageons
et l'expérience cosslett porteur de
beaucoup d'enseignements pour nous
jetons peut considérer qu à un moment
afin de marie jeanne a été le premier
député indépendantiste rassemblé
nationale nous avions une certaine
avance quelque part aujourd'hui nous ont
largement rattrapé peut-être même il
faut l'admettre d'y passer lorsqu'on
voit les résultats du dernier scrutin
encore ça veut dire que le peuple corse
fait confiance à ses élus j'ai aussi
d'excellentes relations avec monsieur
jean guy talamoni qui le président de
l'assemblée lancé le président jean yves
à l'honneur de claude lise qui a fait
les choses sont un peu différentes parce
que l'assemblée a beaucoup je vous vois
des pouvoirs que il faut pouvoir il faut
de voir ces institutions centrales
admettre que 25 ans de moyenne relation
très
enrichissante que j'entretiens avec ces
élus là avec le goûter bozo sommes bien
évidemment qui fait partie du groupe gdr
et je peux dire un très modestement que
dans son choix du groupe gdr l'entretien
que j'ai eu avec lui joannie l'on nous
on va pas dire c'est que dans ces années
là haut mais disons que l'entretien que
nous avons eu ensemble n'a pas
désavantager le choix du groupe gdr
léger entretiennent d'excellentes
relations avec deux questions puisqu'il
reste trois minutes avant l'émission
vous êtes député depuis cinq ans ces
camps et demi maintenant vous avez vous
êtes vous avez été vice président de
l'assemblée de martinique mais vous avez
dû laisser ses fonctions pour rester
conseiller en raison du cumul des
mandats vous avez été conseiller général
de sainte luce nous avait été conseiller
régional vous avez été candidat à la
mairie de sainte luce
lequel de ces mandats de ses
responsabilités politiques vous plaît le
plus si je puis dire si vous avez un
choix faits ont finalement tous les
mandats que j'ai occupés n'ont plus
vraiment s'est impliqué ce exige des
qualités qui sont peut-être différente
mais ça fait partie justement de la
formation de pouvoir un petit peu touché
à tout pour ensuite faire un choix
aujourd'hui je me sens à l'aise dans le
rôle de parlementaire
g je crois pouvoir le dire en bleu mans
je bénéficie d'un soutien public un
soutien populaire fort c'est ce qui fait
ma force c'est ce qui a fait que j'ai pu
résister aux attaques les plus sordides
les plus malhonnêtes à mon encontre et
j'ai envie de redonner à ce peuple
martiniquais du nom au sud d'ailleurs
parce que je ne me cantonne pas bien sûr
je suis le député du sud mais je me
contente pas qu'au sud les territoires
ah oui très clairement très clairement
l'échelle du territoire il ya un travail
à faire et
d'ailleurs je peux vous annoncer que
très prochainement nous avons commencé
toute une série de réunions de compte
rendu de mandat du parlementaire que je
suis mais ces réunions là ne vont pas se
cantonner à la circonscription du sud
nous allons partir à porter
l'information et recueillir les
doléances de toute la martinique vous
avez à l'instant plus au début de
l'émission évoqué des attaques
malhonnêtes ou malencontre portées
contre moi à titre personnel ou en tant
que dirigeant politique
en clair allez-vous porter plainte
contre le blog bondamanjak depuis des
années vous conçu de sa vindicte voulant
soumettre prochainement ou en tout cas
que les choses sont en cours ou et
depuis un moment sont en cours on verra
ce que ça donnera je veux dire je veux
pas donner trop d'importance à ça
vraiment ça c'est derrière moi je suis
focalisé sur l'avenir alors mais ce qui
a été le plus dur c'est pas les attaques
de ses pas des attaques les attaques de
quelqu'un qui ne représente pas grand
chose ça fait pas mal c'est un certain
moment lorsque je me suis rendu compte
que il y avait une tolérance y avait des
soutiens en bas fille à cette démarche
et se soutiennent et ne venaient pas
forcément d'adversaires politiques
venaient de ce qu'on peut appeler au
sens large mon propre camp politique et
c'est ce qui a été le plus difficile à
transcender
aujourd'hui je vous assure que j'ai
transcender tout ça et que les coûts
d'où qu'ils viennent ne me font plus mal
et je suis plus que jamais déterminé à
oeuvrer à donner une bonne image de mon
pays à oeuvrer pour la martinique
antilles au delà du qu'en dira-t-on
au delà des ddd du de cette idée de
complot permanent des conteneurs
n'entretiennent nuance ou une divergence
je suis plus que jamais déterminé à
travailler efficacement avec des
résultats à la clé au service de mon
pays
toute dernière question qu'il appelle
peut être une réponse très courte jean
philippe miller est ce qu'aujourd'hui là
vous êtes optimiste et confiant pour la
prochaine campagne sucrière notamment
par rapport à la situation de l'usiné du
galion de trinité l'occasion de phase
compliquée j'ai dit et je suis tombé
j'ai développé l'idée que ce couplage à
al bioman n'était pas une bonne chose
et dans mon intervention en plénière
j'ai mis en doute la sécurité de ce
couplage là et j'ai dit qu il expliqué
qu'ils risquaient de se faire là tu sais
ce que qu'entre qu'on entrait vous avez
toujours des excuses et et j'ai plus que
jamais avait des inquiétudes sur la
prochaine campagne sucrière
mais celle d'après celle des hommes dans
les années à venir
aucune garantie n'a été donnée quant au
respect de ses engagements là et je dis
que la réparation de la chaudière ont
été une meilleure décision et on a pu
respecter des mieux respecter les délais
mieux respecter la nécessité de la
prochaine campagne on qu'il ya donc un
film senna faire assure en tout cas je
n'assume pas et je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ce choix le couplage à l'hommage
les suffisamment dit vous l'aurez mais
je ne vais pas pour autant me jouer des
difficultés que j'avais déjà prédit bien
6 janvier 2011 ce sera le mot de la fin
pour terminer cette émission face à la
première réalisée aujourd'hui par
claudine était le biais l'émission
présentée aujourd'hui par bertrand
caruge merci de l'attention des gens
meurent à bientôt
face à la première
[Musique]